vous avez quand même été peut-être pas
tous vielles tout à fait dont on parle
beaucoup actuellement mais quasiment
peut-être le premier collabos de france
et oui finalement ce qui est quand même
ça sourire très vivace et pourtant j'en
avais j'avais que six ans puisque c'est
un an 40
et c'est vrai que j'ai assumé notre avis
vaste et allemands qui étaient j'étais
sur une petite route au bord du village
où on est et où ma famille s'était hélas
ma famille maternelle avec mon grand
père jimmy on s'était s'étaient cachés
et j'étais tout séduit les pauvres là où
les riches non allonger les défendre il
est au port il était beau et puis il a
fait il avait fait fort mais il a fait
fortune ils sont les deux grands pères
le bien français et celui qui est pas
tout à fait français ils sont riches
tous les deux tout les deux
après tout le monde alors s'il précision
comme ça bon voilà vous êtes sur le bord
de la route
et alors jeté sur le bord de la route
est effectivement je me souviens très
bien de ce mont premiers allemands qui
étaient dix au t2 ce qui est sûr un
side-car donc ils étaient 2 qui s'est
approché et qui m'a tendu une plaque de
chocolat
ce qu'ont fait les américains 20 ans
plus tard comme quoi ya pas deux et cinq
ans plus tard et j'ai accepté cette
plaque de chocolat et c'est vrai que les
bruits couraient saïss que ce que les
bruits les bruits couraient que les
allemands des années du choquel
occasionnés aux enfants et ma mère est
arrivée m'a donné ça ma première claque
mais c'était une plaque de 2,2 peur de
terreur s'était pas évidemment les
méchancetés pour moi pour me retirer les
chocolats de la bouche bien évidemment
je vais m'efforcer la vallée et c'est
comme ça qu effectivement j'ai toujours
gardé un souvenir attendri de mon père
mon premier allemand si je peux aider
j'espère qu'il disait qu'elle étende
occupations favorites il a dit
l'occupation allemande
c'était un peu au câble et en même temps
vous avez vous un souvenir ému de la
auscitains garceau un petit camarade à
vous qui êtes à côté de vous et qui est
beau et à qui on a mis une petite et et
puis ça c'était au lycée rollin c'est à
10 appels de courdemanges maintenant
c'était au lycée rollin effectivement je
me souviens très bien de son visage il
était comme moi bouclé mais noir avait
des yeux très noir mais très brillant
effectivement c'est là aussi j'ai connu
cette première chose enfin monstrueuse
qui ensuite s'est passé pendant ces cinq
ans c'est la disparition petit à petit
de l'homme ça d'aider des juifs qui
vivaient en france et ce petit garçon
était juif
je ne sais pas très bien ce que c'était
qu'un juif à cette époque il avait une
petite étoile trouvé ça très joli et un
beau jour sa place est resté vide et le
le professeur n'a rien dit à la fin de
la classe il a dit vous ne le reverrez
plus et je me suis fait expliquer mais
bien longtemps après ce que ça voulait
dire je crois que mes parents ne
voulaient pas me le dire parce que
c'était c'était très très émouvant
dernier souvenir drôle donc toujours
dans le château mais là vous êtes grange
est devenu un jeune homme vous
introduisez une trompette vous jouer de
la trompette dans les comptes du château
pour qu évidemment pas que la famille
n'écoute pas oui je la bouche est très
bien
gt gt tout en haut vous étiez un bon jeu
de trompette un non juste un joueur de
trompette de bordel oui vous allez jouer
dans les bordels après c'est enfoncer -
les moments
monsieur chaillou il parle de cambrioler
parce qu'il était pauvre moi j'avais
rien à cambrioler que des moments de
liberté
ce que j'essayais vraiment s'était piqué
à droite ou à gauche des moments de
liberté pour ça j'y mettais tout mais
j'y passais tout mon temps et toute mon
imagination
effectivement j'arrivais à à tromper la
vigilance de mes parents le soir
ce taux que ma grand mère se coucher tôt
donc c'était pas trop dur et à partir
dans le parc la nuit grimper sur un mur
retrouver des copains qui m'attendait en
voiture allait jouer dans un linceul
bordel de la ville d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle avait d'autres la tempête ce
qu'elle arrive valenciennes valenciennes
je voulais que je dise non du bordel
aussi pour flâner à oui nous aimons mais
je crois qu'ils vont s'aimer après le
grand sphinx ou stardust haut juste
comme ça
et alors je jouais avec une casquette
enfoncée jusqu'aux yeux pour pas qu'on
vous reconnaît pas comme en grèce encore
que si quelqu'un de la famille était là
s'arrêter aussi ennuyeux pour lui que
pour moi j'ai pas lu mon père est et
comme vous avez annoncé à cette famille
quand même et surtout à la famille bien
française que vous vouliez devenir
comédien comment ça s'est passé
pas trop bien par trop bien je venais de
rater mon bac pour la deuxième fois
je parle du bac philo j'ai eu mon bac 2
le premier parce qu'à l'époque j'avais
littéraire et ensuite il ya la philo
j'ai raté mes deux bac philo et c'est là
que j'ai annoncée je voulais être acteur
et pourquoi pourquoi vouliez tractel je
crois qu'il y avait quelque chose au
fond - qui parce que je vois pas ce que
j'aurais pu faire d'autre maintenant
mais il y avait aussi une sorte de
provocation
à cette époque on faisait pas de
politique alors la manière dont je me
suis dit qu'est-ce qui peut le plus on
meurt dès mes parents
comédien ses comédiens six molière on
l'enterrait pas et quand vous arrivez au
conservatoire vous le fils du maître
qu'est ce que vous fait jouer alors
mamie valais ce qui était alors
forcément j'étais acteur en plus j'étais
un valet et j'avais tout pour déplaire à
ma famille si elle m'avait vu jouer
prince de hombourg ça peut être raté là
je suis allé en plus j'étais avaler je
devais dire garder mon maître justement
je parle que je suis bien que je
trouvais important de vous voir un autre
là c'était l'horreur c'est vrai que
c'était c'était beaucoup quand même
est-ce que vous écrirez d'autres livres
ou bien je crois pas que j'écrirais des
souvenirs de 2,2 d'acteur je crois que
je si j'ai envie d'écrire j'aurais envie
d'aller un peu plus loin et décide alors
de raconter d'histoires plus plus
imaginaires mais les souvenirs d'acteur
c'est au fond c'est ce qu'on m'a demandé
d'écrire au départ et ce livre il y
avait trois pages c'était la préface ma
préface sur l'enfance je me suis aperçu
que ça m'intéressait beaucoup plus de
raconter mon enfance que de raconter les
souvenirs
je sais que j'adore depardieu et j'adore
carmet et bien vous avez fait le bon
choix
[Musique]